l'autre titre à l'étranger c'est la
démission du leader des serbes de bosnie
radovan karadzic il a accepté par écrit
de se démettre de ses mandats une
décision accueillie avec satisfaction
par l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale en attendant que radovan
karadic comme radio magik comparaissent
devant le tribunal de la haye dorothée
olliéric radovan karadzic a toujours
rêvé d'une grande série
un rêve ou plutôt une obsession qu'il
l'a poussé à cautionner le nettoyage
ethnique de nombreux massacres aussi
aujourd'hui karadzic n'est plus qu'un
hors-la-loi honni par la communauté
internationale inculpé pour crimes de
guerre crimes contre l'humanité et
génocide
ce matin radovan karadzic a abandonné
officiellement toutes ses fonctions
politiques
une démission de la présidence de la
république serbe qui signe un peu plus
son déclin ce retrait de la vie
politique a été obtenu par richard
holbrooke l'émissaire américain surnommé
le kissinger des balkans ne fait
pourtant aucun triomphalisme les
criminels de guerre dit il devrait se
trouver à la haine là où se trouve le
tribunal pénal international qui a
délivré des mandats d'arrêt
internationaux contre karadzic et mladic
l'otp y voit cette décision comme une
étape importante significative
il ya un premier pas est un premier pas
seulement sur une route qui doit mener
au plus vite les accusés direction la
haye ap aller dans le fief de karadzic
c'est la stupeur ici c'est la république
serbe de bosnie ici karadzic est
ailleurs
c'est dommage pour tout le peuple serbe
mais heureusement on en a d'autres comme
les pôles remplacer dans l'ombre ils
sont encore nombreux à propager les
thèses ultra nationalistes de karadzic
après